once we invited a guest
forar he said it is discouraged to talk
whilst eating in the religion of Islam
is he
correct I don't know of any Hadith of
the Prophet wasallam where he said that
you should not speak while eating Etc in
fact Allah says in the Quran in 4:59
that if there's a difference go back to
Allah and his there's no text in the
Quran which says you should not speak
while eating there's no text in the had
in which the prophet commanded you
should not speak while eating in fact
there are Hadith exactly the opposite
the prophet spoke while eating for
example if you read the Hadith of s
Muslim volume number three Hadith number
5093 where the Prophet was served
vinegar and he said that vinegar is a
good food while eating there other
Hadith in which the prophet said that do
not eat with your left hand for the
Satan eats with the left hand again this
is while eating Hadith of s bukari
volume number seven Hadith number
5376 where the Beloved Prophet wasallam
said there was a boy was eating with the
prophet and he was moving his hand
around so the prophet said eat with the
right hand and eat from what is close to
you so this he said while eating so all
this Hadith prove that there is no
restriction for speaking while eating
Whenever there a difference go back to
Allah andol and you'll get the answer